ก็สวัสดีครับพี่สวัสดีน้องเรียมสวัสดีนัก
เรียนด้วยครับสวัสดีเปล่าวันนี้วันนี้
กลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับพี่อาตี้แล้วก็น้อง
เวียงน้องเรียมคนสวยคนเดิมว่าโอเคแค่นะ
ครับ
อ้าก่อนอื่นก่อนอื่นที่เราจะเรียนภาษาไทย
กันนะครับอ้าวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรครับ
วันนี้วันอังคารวันอังคาร
ว้าววันนี้วันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่ครับวัน
อังคารที่ 19  19 ใช่แล้ววันอังคารที่ 19
เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้เดือน
ตุลาคมเดือนนี้เดือนตุลาคมในครับปีคศอะไร
ครับข้อ
2021  5 ปีคปี
2021 ไหมครับอ่าแล้วปีคศอะไรครับพ.ศ
2500  64
64 ว้าวโอเคแล้ววันนี้วันนี้ที่เราคุย
กันอยู่
ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วครับตอนนี้
13:50 น
13:50 นนนา
13:50 นใช้โอเคตอนนี้พร้อมแล้วนะครับ
พร้อมแล้วที่จะเรียนภาษาไทยกันหนาวอันนี้
มีเรื่องอะไรมีเรื่องอะไรมาสอนนักเรียน
กันครับวันนี้
เราจะพูดถึง
ครอบครัว 1 ครอบครัว
1 ครอบครัวที่วันหยุดใช่ไหมเป็นวันหยุด
ดีของครอบครัว
ช่วยกันช่วยกันทำงานบ้านใช่ไหมครับอ่าเรา
จะพูดกันเรื่องของครอบครัวเที่ยงไหมตัว
ว่าเห็นครับน้าป๊อบ
อ๊อฟครัวนี้เราไปดูกันว่าในครอบครัวนี้มี
ใครบ้างครับในครอบครัวนี้มีพี่เอารูปมา
ให้ดูแล้วนะครับอ๋อเรียมเห็นค่ะเรียนเห็น
เห็นใครบ้างครับรูปนี้เห็นแม่นี่แม่พ่อมี
แม่อยู่นี่ครับคนนี้วันนี้เป็นแม่
แม่นะป้าครอบครัวนี้มีคุณแม่หนึ่งคนมีหา
คุณแม่ว้าวคุณแม่นี่เป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหม
ครับใช่ค่ะแม่ถ้าเป็นหิงค์หน้าตาๆๆ 5
เป็นผู้หญิงเหมือนเหมือนน้องเรียมน้อง
เรียมก็เป็นผู้หญิง
ชาไข่มันเป็นผู้หญิงขาว
แล้วก็เห็นเห็นใครเขาห่อมีลูกสาวด้วยลูก
สาวลูกสาวก็เป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหมครับ
ใช้ค่ะพ่อลูกสาวเป็นผู้หญิงอ่ะเป็นคนนี้
นี้ใช่ไหมครับนี่นี่คนนี้เป็นลูกสาวว่า
ว้าวบ้านนี้มีคุณแม่มีลูกสาวน่าเป็นผู้
หญิงทั้งสองคนเลยหน้าแล้วแล้ว
แล้วเรียมก็เห็น
เขาก็
มีพ่ออยู่ในรูปนี้ด้วยอ๋ออยู่นี่เนื้อ
เพลงคุณพ่ออยู่โน้นอยู่ข้างหลังข้างหลัง
ไกลไกลๆๆใช่ครับชื่อดงนี้อ๋ออ๋อคุณพ่อคุณ
พ่อคุณพ่อนี่ไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงใช่ไหมครับไม่
ใช่ผู้หญิงไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงค่ะพ่อเป็น
ผู้ชายขอเป็นผู้ชายอ่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ก็เป็น
ผู้ชายหน้าคุณพ่อเป็นผู้ชายส่วนคุณแม่คุณ
แม่เป็นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงหาและลูกสาวลูกสาว
ก็เป็นผู้หญิงเหมือนกันอ๋อเลียมก็เป็นผู้
หญิง
มากจ้าใช่โอเคแล้วในรูปนี้รูปนี้ครอบครัว
นี้กำลังทำอะไรกันครับ
ทำดีอะไรกันก็เตรียมเห็นคุณพ่อกำลังตัด
กิ่งไม้อ๋ออ๋อกำลังตัดกิ่งไม้ใช่ไหมครับ
นี่คุณพ่อกำลังตัดกิ่งไม้นี่ครับมีต้นไม้
อันนี้เป็นต้นไม้ต้นสูงมีต้นไม้เยอะเลย
ต้นไม้คุณ Pot ตัดออก
ตัดออกมีตัดให้เหลือแค่นี้ตัดเพราะไม่
ครับอ่าเขาจะตัดกิ่งไม้ 5 ตัดกิ่งไม้ให้
ครับหน้าเหมือนที่น้องยังไว้ก็จะมีใบไม้
ขอเขามีใบไม้สีเขียวอ้าใบไม้สีเขียวเยอะ
เลย
ใช่ค่ะคุณพ่อก็ตัดกิ่งไม้ออกตัดใบไม้ออก
ด้วยใช่ไหมครับตัดใบไม้ออกด้วยค่ะอ๋อ
195 อ้าตัดใบไม้ออกด้วยแล้วคุณแม่กับลูก
สาวมาช่วยกันทำอะไรครับ
ตอนนี้คุณแม่กำลังใส่ถุงมือขอใส่ถุงมือ
ถุงมืออันนี้ใช่ไหมครับมีถุงมือหาใส่ถุง
มือข้างนี้ก่อนข้างไหนครับข้างนี้เป็น
ข้างข้างซ้ายใช่มั้ย
นี่ถุงมือข้างซ้ายของลูกสาวแอฟคุณแม่
กำลังใส่ถุงมือให้ว้าวน่ารักเธอเลยครับ
ถุงแล้วอะไรคะแต่ถ้าถุงมือถุงมือสี
สีเขียว 5 ถุงมือสีเขียวสีเขียวเหมือนสี
เขียวเหมือนกับต้นไม้นี่ต้นไม้ก็สีเขียว
เหมือนกันสีเขียวแบบเธอเคยเดี๋ยวๆอ้าวใช่
ครับนี่น้องเรียกว่าถุงมือสีเขียวน้อง
เรียมวาดถุงมือถุงเก่งมากเลยเป็นถุงมือสี
เขียววาดเร็วด้วยฮ่าๆนักเรียนนักเรียนดู
ผู้ดูน้องเรียมวาดรูปพรรณนะครับเพียววาด
เร็วมากโอเคโอเคว่าถุงมือสีเขียวนะครับ
ใส่ข้างซ้ายไปแล้วแล้วข้างขวาข้างขวาใส่
หรือยังครับ
ยังค่ะอ๋อข้างขวายังไม่ได้ใส่ใช่ไหมนี่
นี่ใช่ยังไม่ได้ใส่เลยยังไม่ได้ใส่ไหม
ครับนักท่องเที่ยวมาเห็นไหมลูกสาวใช่ค่ะ
เขาใส่ลูกสาวกำลังกำถุงมือสีเขียว
กำลังจำถุงมือสีเขียวเอาไว้ในมืออีกข้าง
นึงที่แต่ยังไม่ได้ใส่ยังไม่ได้ใส่แท้
โอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวคุณแม่ก็จะใส่ให้ใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่
โอเคขอลูกสาวใส่ครับ
ลืมก็เห็นลูกสาวกับแม่ใส่รองเท้าบูทอ๋อ
อ๋อใช่ครับมีเป็นรองเท้าบูทมีรองเท้าบูท
จะคู่ยาวแบบนี้จะยาวกว่ารองเท้าปกตินี่
ครับยาวกว่าได้เป็นรองเท้าบูทสีเขียวสี
เขียวอ่ะรองเท้าบูทสีเขียวเหมือนกับถุง
มือเลยถุงมือก็สีเขียวเหมือนกัน
หนาแล้วลูกสาวหรอคะลูกสาวใส่รองเท้าบูทสี
อะไรลูกสาวใส่รองเท้าบูทถ้าไม่ใช่สีเขียว
ไม่ใช่สีเขียวลูกสาวใส่รองเท้าบูทสีสี
อะไรครับนักเรียนนะฮ่าๆๆสีอะไรครับถูก
ต้องครับลูกสาวใส่รองเท้าบูทสีเหลืองครับ
นี่รองเท้าบูทสีเหลืองว้าวรองเท้าบูทสี
เหลืองครูบูทสีเหลืองใช่ค่ะตายสำหรับเด็ก
สำหรับลูกสาวคู่เล็กของคุณแม่คู่ใหญ่ใหญ่
กว่าอ้าครับ
ใช่ค่ะหน้าเสร็จ
คุณพ่อคุณแม่ลูกสาวใส่กางเกงขายาวนะคะอ๋อ
อ๋อใช่ครับทุกทุกๆคนคุณพ่อคุณแม่แล้วก็
ลูกสาวใส่กางเกงขายาวทุกคนใช้แล้วก็มี
ครับกางเกงขา
ยาวกางเกงขายาวมากมายอ้าใช่ครับทุกคนใส่
กางเกงขายาวขายาวกางเกงขายาว
ขายาว
ขอเมียตีเห็นเห็นทุกคนใส่กางเกงขายาวแล้ว
ทุกคนก็ใส่เสื้อ
ใส่เสื้อแขนแขนยาวด้วยเหมือนกันใช่ไหม
ครับแขนยาวๆนี่ใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
เสื้อแขนยาวคุณแม่ก็ใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
เสื้อคุณแม่ใส่เสื้อแขนยาวสีอะไรครับน้อง
เรียม
สีฟ้าค่ะอ๋ออ๋อสีฟ้าเสื้อแขนยาวสีฟ้าสี
ฟ้า
ใช่สีแล้วโป้สาวหน้าขอ
[เพลง]
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
โป้แนวหน้าถ้าพร้อมแล้วไปกันเลยครับนัดหา
นี้นี่วายข่าวเป็ดแล้วใส่ถุงมือเสร็จแล้ว
ลูกสาวใส่ถุงมือคุณแม่ก็ใส่ถุงมือเหมือน
กันนี่คุณแม่ก็ใส่ถุงมือกัน 5 โหลเตรียม
ก็เห็นว่าลูกสาวใส่ผ้าพันคอ
หาลูกสาวใส่ผ้าพันคอด้วยใจครับมีภาพพันคอ
อยู่ตรงนี้อ่าใส่ผ้าพันคอด้วยผ้าพันคอสี
อะไรคะตี้ผ้าพันคอผ้าพันคอสีชมพู
สีชมพูเหมือนกันใช่ไหมสีชมพูหูครับ
ค่าพันคอ
นายห้ามกูสีชมพู
น่ารักค่ะน่ารักสุดท้ายครับเด็กเด็กน้อย
ใส่ผ้าพันคอสีชมพูตัวเล็กๆน่ารักๆทุกคน
พร้อมแล้วใส่ถุงมือมาแล้ว
อ่ะใส่ถุงมือแล้วทำอะไรกันต่อครับทีนี้
เรามาทำอะไรกัน
แล้วก็เก็บกิ่งไม้
ช่วยกันช่วยคุณพ่อช่วยคุณแม่เก็บกิ่งไม้
ที่คุณพ่อตัดออกมาแล้วนี่คุณพ่อใช้
เครื่องตัดกิ่งไม้ตัดกิ่งไม้ก็มีร่วงลงมา
บนนี้นะมีกิ่งไม้ที่คุณพ่อตัดตัดออกมาตัด
ออกมานี่อยู่บนนี้เยอะแยะเลยมาเรามาช่วย
กันช่วยกันว่าเห็บ 1 ไม้ที่ตัดเสร็จแล้ว
เก็บไปไหนครับเก็บไว้ที่ใครถุงค่ะอ้าเก็บ
ไปใส่ถุงอ่ะคุณแม่กับลูกสาวมาช่วยกันเก็บ
กิ่งไม้ใส่ถุงถุงนี้ถุงนี้ใช่ไหมครับใช่
ข้าวอ่ะถุงนี้เหมือนที่น้องเรียนกำลังวาด
เป็นถุงใบใหญ่เลยหูใบได้ใหญ่ได้ถุงใบใหญ่
เลยอ่ะเอามาใส่กิ่งไม้โอเคๆน้องเกมว่ามี
มีอะไรด้วยครับ
พรุ่งนี้สีอะไรคะอย่าพี่หนีสีอะไรทุ่งนี้
เขียวสีเขียว
สีเขียวไหมน้องเรียมเห็นว่าถุงสีอะไรครับ
เตรียมคิดวะครับพรุ่งนี้สีเขียว
สีเขียวเหมือนกันนะครับสีเขียวเหมือน
เหมือนอ่าต้นไม้ไหมเหมือนต้นไม้ไหมเหมือน
ได้ไหมเหมือนอ๋อสีเหมือน
ดีไม่ดีครับโอเคอะเรามาช่วยกันเก็บกิ่ง
ไม้ทรายถุงกันแล้วแค่มาคุณแม่คุณแม่ชี้ไป
นี่ใช้มือนิ้วชี้ชี้ไปชี้ไปที่เก่งไม้นะ
ครับอ่ะมาเก็บตรงนี้ลูกเก็บตรงนี้ค่ะดู
อ่าลูกสาวก็อ้าหรือสาวก็มองคุณแม่ฟังคุณ
แม่คุณแม่บอกให้ไปเก็บตรงนี้เก็บตรงนี้
อ๋อ
หาวก็จะเดินไปๆก็เดินไปช่วยกันเก็บเก็บ
ได้ครับ
เออใช้ๆเก็บตัวไหนคะเก็บกิ่งไม้ใส่ถุงนี่
หน่วยงานเก็บกิ่งไม้ทรายถุงใส่ถุง
ใส่ลงไปใส่ลงไปใส่ลงไปเยอะมีเยอะเพราะใส่
ลงไปเยอะแล้วถุงเป็นยังไงครับตอนนี้
ถุงเต็มค่ะ 5 ถุงเต็มแล้วมีกิ่งไม้เยอะ
เลยคุณพ่อคุณพ่อตัดเยอะเลยคุณพ่อตัดสิไม้
เยอะเลยอ่ะคุณแม่กับลูกสาวช่วยกันเก็บใส่
ถุงจริงไหมเต็มแล้วเต็มถุงแล้วทีนี้แต่
ยังมีอีกถุงนึงนะคะพี่อาร์ตี้อ่อนยังมี
อีกทุ่มนึงนี่ที่ว่างอ๋ออ๋อถุงนี้ยังไม่
เต็มยังไม่มีกิ่งไม้เลยอ่ะอ่าโอเค
ก็เอามาใส่ถุงนี้มาเก็บใส่ถุงมีอีกอ่า
เก็บไปเรื่อยๆช่วยกันช่วยกันเก็บน้าช่วย
คุณพ่อเก็บช่วยคุณแม่เก็บหน้าเก๋ดีแล้ว
ที่นี่คุณแม่กำลังทำอะไรอยู่คะคุณแม่
กำลังเอ่อกำลังถือถุงถือถือถุงมีถุงใบนี้
ถุงใบนี้เป็นถุงเปล่าของป่าวนี่ใบนี้ถุง
ป่าวไม่มีหมายคุณแม่ถึงยกมือเดียวยกมือ
เดียวขึ้นมายกได้เลยเพราะว่ามันมันเป็นไง
ครับเปล่ามันเอาใช่มันเบามันไม่หนักไม่มี
กิ่งไม้ถุงก็เลยบ่าวยกได้เลยนะครับแต่ถุง
นี้พรุ่งนี้มีกิ่งไม้เต็มเลยเต็มเลยยก
ยกไม่ได้มาให้ไหวเพราะว่าเป็นยังไงครับ
เพราะว่ามันน่ามันหนักยกไม่ไหวยกไม่ไหว
สายใช่ไหมได้ครับโอเค
ถ้าเรารักสนุกมากค่ะถ้าน้องเรียมน้อง
เรียมเคยตัดกิ่งไม้ที่บ้านไหมเคยช่วยคุณ
พ่อ
ตัดกิ่งไม้แล้วเก็บใบไม้ใส่ถุงแบบนี้ไหม
ครับเคยค่ะเลยขอช่วยเก็บใบไม้ใส่ถุงมือ
ครับผมพี่อาร์ตี้เวลาพี่อาร์ตี้ตัดกิ่ง
ไม้พี่ก็ให้ลูกมาช่วยเก็บใบไม้เหมือนกัน
เลยว่าๆเราจะได้ช่วยกันทำงานจะได้เสร็จ
เร็วๆนะครับอ่ะดีครับหน้าเราต้องช่วยกัน
นะครับโอเคดีมากเลยค่ะหาดีมากต่อไปว้าว
นี่ตอนนี้หรอกนับโว้ย
ที่ไม้เสร็จแล้วได้เสร็จแล้วเฮียตี
เห็นเราเก็บกิ่งไม้พ่อแม่ลูกช่วยกันเก็บ
กี่ไหมเยอะเลยก็มีกิ่งไม้ที่ตัดออกมาเยอะ
เลยมีอยู่กี่ถุงเงี้ยมีอยู่กี่ถุงครับ
เรียกเห็น 4 ถุง 4 ถุงใช่ไหมโหโอ้มี 1  2
3  4 วาวมีกิ่งไม้ทั้งหมด 4 ถุงวาล์ว
เยอะมากเลยมากเลยถุงใหญ่ๆเลยๆครับหาอ้อ
แล้วคุณข้อเดินมาคุณพ่อ
ยกนิ้วโป้งให้แปลว่าอะไรครับทำไมคุณพ่อ
ถึงยกนิ้วโป้งคุณพ่อโกรธหรือเปล่า
โกรธไหม
คุณพ่อไม่บอกว่า
บอกว่าไงครับมากอ๋ออ๋อเก่งมากๆอ๋อแบบนี้
แปลว่าเก่งใช่ไหมเก่งมากกว้างมากๆไม่ได้
แปลว่าโกรธไม่ได้โกรธหรอหมอเขาหน้าโกรธฮา
เพราะว่าคุณพ่อยิ้มใช่ไหมคุณพ่อหญิงค่ะก็
ยิ้มได้คุณพ่อยิ้มยกนิ้วโป้งอาเก่งมากๆ
ใครเก่งครับใครเก่งลูกสาวเก่งขอรูปสาว
เก่งมากๆอ่ะคุณแม่เก่งมากๆโอเคเยี่ยมเลย
เก่งมากสองคนครับแล้วคุณแม่ถืออะไรอยู่ใน
เมืองค่ะคุณแม่ถืออะไรอ่ะคุณแม่พี่
อาร์ตี้คิดว่าคุณแม่คือไม้กวาดถือไม้กว่า
5 ที่เอามากวาดใบไม้กวาดใบไม้เพื่อใส่ลง
ไปในถุงอ้ามากวาดใบไม้ไม้กวาดก็จะมีด้าม
ยาวๆนี่เดี๋ยวพี่อาร์ตี้ว่าไม้กวาดจะมี
ด้ามยาวแบบนี้ให้น้าแล้วก็มีตัวใหม่กว่า
นี้ตัวไม่กว่า
หน้าแบบนี้เป็นไม้กวาดเอามากวาดใบไม้แล้ว
ก็อาจๆกวาดใบไม้ไปรวมกันก็เอามาใส่ถุง
ชาย
นายครับหน้าตอนนี้ก็ไม่เข้าแม้วๆเสร็จ
แล้ว
ว้าว
เร็วไหมเพราะว่าเรากันเราช่วยกันหลาย
คนก็เสร็จเร็วนี้คุณพ่อคนนึงคุณแม่คนนึง
แล้วก็ลูกสาวอีกคนหนึ่งช่วยกันช่วยกันทำ
งานงานก็เสร็จเร็วนะครับอ่าเลยค่ะอ้า
เยี่ยมเลยครับโอเคแล้ววันนี้บทเรียนของ
เราก็จบแล้วเพราะว่ามีพี่แอ๊ดตี้แล้วก็
น้องเรียมช่วยกันช่วยไปที่การลาวช่วยกัน
สอนนักเรียนนะครับแล้วแค่แล้ววันนี้นัก
เรียนได้คำศัพท์ใหม่จากบทเรียนของเปียตี้
แล้วก็น้องเหลี่ยมไหมครับอ่ะถ้ามีคำศัพท์
ใหม่ช่วยคีย์คำศัพท์ใหม่ที่ Comment ให้
หน่อยอ่าเผื่อมีคำถามถ้านักเรียนมีคำถาม
เกี่ยวกับคำศัพท์ใหม่ขี่ไว้ในคอมเมนต์อ่ะ
ค่ะเดี๋ยวเปียตีกับน้องเรียมจะเข้ามาดู
แล้วก็อธิบายนะครับแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้า
ข่าวหน้าคราวหน้าเราจะหาเขาหน้าเราจะ
เรียนอะไรอ่าเรื่องอะไรกันเดี๋ยวนักเรียน
คอยติดตามข่าวนะครับใช้ค่ะงั้นสำหรับวัน
นี้นะครับต้องต้องลาไปก่อนครับคุณชาย
ขอบคุณนักเรียนนะขอบคุณ
ครับผมสวัสดีครับทุกคนครับสวัสดีนักเรียน
ด้วยครับจ้าแล้วเจอกันใหม่จ้าคะบ๊ายบาย
บ๊ายบาย